Thank you for the Akasuba!
Thank you!
I said in the chat, I was like, no!
No!
Akasuba, no!
If you notice something different about me...
I... I am not...
I am not an angel.
But I have a halo.
I have...
Shiroko.
Look at her.
Shiroko, she's voiced by Ogura Yui Maiseyu Oshi.
I'm here for Blue Archive!
I'm here...
Where are the horns?
Shiroko doesn't have horns?
There's actually a lot of characters that have horns in Blue Archive.
Oh gosh.
This is gonna turn into a stream about me wanting to talk about...
Blue Archive, I think.
Then...
Playing Mahjong, maybe.
I'm actually quite nervous.
Because...
I was like, oh my god.
I'm so nervous.
What if I just like...
I don't know.
Because I get really embarrassed about like...
I just get embarrassed.
I was like...
It's like...
Learning something like this.
What if I don't get it and people think I'm so dumb?
Because...
This is actually not my first time trying to learn Mahjong.
I've tried to learn before in the past.
But I...
Um...
I...
I just didn't get it at all.
It's okay.
We already think that.
Yippee!
It's okay if you don't.
Plenty of streamers don't.
Okay.
Will you guys help me?
It takes a bit before it clicks.
I've had...
I've had friends try to teach me.
I've tried to learn through Mahjong Soul.
Um...
I've tried learning from...
Uh...
Maybe I'm not like...
Applying myself.
As much as I should.
You know?
Maybe I'm just kind of like...
Whatever.
Just...
Click...
Click block.
Set block.
Something happened.
I don't know.
I know nothing about Blue Archive nor Mahjong.
Well...
Today you might...
Learn about...
Both.
At least Blue Archive.
I can...
I can teach you at least about...
Blue Archive.
Which...
Look at these things.
These girls.
Oh my gosh.
They're so cute.
Right?
That's Shiroko.
She's so cute.
I love...
She's kind of like...
Kudere.
But she's also like...
Silly.
Which is what I really like about her.
Because she's...
She's got like a cool personality.
Thank you.
Gacha funds.
No gacha funds.
Um...
As a Mahjong player, anyone who tells you they know how to play is lying.
That makes me feel a little better.
Yeah.
So...
Shiroko is goofy as hell.
She's so goofy.
She's so...
She's so silly.
Silly Kudere is peak.
Yes.
Right?
I think...
It's like why I love...
Um...
Why I love free runs so much.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Number one beginner rule.
Don't call tiles except to win.
What if I know their phone number?
And what if I'm like looking for a little bit of a booty call?
Then can I call them?
What if they tell me...
What if they're playing hard to get?
And I'm just trying to like...
You know...
Show that I have interest.
Non-gacha funds.
Thank you.
Yeah.
That's acceptable.
Okay.
An official Mahjong Soul anime came out today.
Wait.
That came out today?
Because I saw...
I saw...
That...
That existed.
But it was today?
That's so funny.
I learned from Saki.
So this should be fine.
Um...
I didn't finish Saki.
But what I learned from Saki is that um...
Panties are overrated.
Nobody in that show wears them.
I'm not asking anyone for a booty call.
It's a boo.
Get it?
Boo.
Booty call.
Aru, my beloved.
This is Aru right here.
She looks very cool.
And very like...
Like...
Mysterious and...
Not mysterious.
Maybe like mature.
Mature!
Another M word that I was thinking.
She looks very mature and very cool but she's actually also kind of a girl failure.
This is Hoshino.
She's an ojisan with a tragic past.
And this is Mutsuki.
And she's just a little brat.
She's so cute.
Kind of...
Look.
I'm being...
I'm being nice, okay?
Silly head empty, Aru, my beloved.
Very girl failure.
She is so kusogaki.
Yeah, she is.
Mutsuki is very kusogaki.
She's very cute.
Very, very cute, Sal.
I don't...
There's...
Oh.
I was going to say there's not a single character in Blue Archive that I dislike but I don't think that's true actually.
Okay.
There's one girl in Blue Archive who, her voice, like, she's very cute but her voice just grates on me so bad.
So bad.
Ojisan, very cute.
Bashamin!
Shizuko!
How did you guys know?
Wait, is it not just me?
Oh my gosh.
No way.
Is it not just me?
I feel really validated right now.
Oh my gosh.
I feel...
During the event, there was an event recently in Blue Archive where, like, they did, like, a...
What's the word?
Like a bathing suit.
They were, like...
It was a summer event.
They were all, like, bathing suits and stuff.
And I could barely touch the event because Shizuko was so...
Oh my gosh.
I would click the page and she would talk and I'd be like...
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm, like, covering my ear.
I'm like, stop!
Oh my...
No.
I feel so bad saying that because I'm sure her seiyuu is, like, super cute and super nice and everything.
She's just doing her best.
Oh my gosh.
And Shizuko is so cute herself, you know?
Didn't know Blue Archive got a new student.
Who's the cute one on the bottom left?
Can we pull her yet?
Will her headpats...
We'll give her headpats in the memorial lobby.
Mutsuki?
Wait, can you see?
Okay, good.
I was making sure you couldn't...
Okay.
Her voice is the best part.
It's...
It's definitely a charm point, I'm sure, for some.
But that event specifically made me be like, oh gosh.
Oh gosh.
Literally one of my favorite aspects about Shizuko is her voice.
That's okay!
Like I said, it is a charm point for some people, you know?
It's a charm...
And I like her...
Her recollection very much.
It's very cute.
She is really cute!
She's very cute.
Why are you upset?
Why are you upset, Yun?
Is it because I said Shizuko bad?
I didn't say Shizuko bad.
I didn't say it though.
But as for my favorite Blue Archive characters, I really like...
Hold on, let me just pull up my...
I've had to do this the other day too.
Let's see.
Actually, did I do my dailies today?
I don't know if I played before the reset or not.
Time to do them now.
We will play Mahjong.
Sorry, everybody.
I'm too busy talking about Blue Archive.
It's the only reason I'm here.
So I play...
I don't play the Japanese Blue Archive.
I play the English Blue Archive.
So...
For now, my favorite characters...
I'm really excited though about the...
There's a battle in progress?
I did?
I had a battle in progress?
Wait.
Who?
Oh!
Oopsie.
I'm just gonna forfeit.
Quit mission.
Quit.
Oopsie.
Isn't the EN Blue Archive getting the Railgun character soon?
They are!
BA is awful.
Worst FPS I've ever played.
Oh, yes.
The...
Yeah, you know.
I get it.
Where's the first person?
Okay.
Students.
My baby girls are...
Koharu.
Cherino.
This is not in any order.
But Koharu and Cherino are like...
Two of my top favorites.
I love Cherino a lot.
She's so dumb.
She's...
She's just so stupid.
I really love Toki.
I do like Hoshino a lot too.
Of course I love Shiroko.
I wanna try...
Actually...
I do like Mutsuki but she's like...
Not one of my top top.
Also, isn't her ear supposed to be like pointy?
Doesn't look as pointy here.
Toki, my beloved.
I actually have a dakimakura of Toki.
I got it at Comiket.
It's...
She's really sexy in it.
I remember seeing...
I remember seeing it from the line waiting to get in.
And...
I was like...
Oh...
I...
Have to go there.
I have to...
Have to go get that.
So...
Because I wasn't familiar with the artist.
But...
I went to Ayami's booth.
And then I went to...
Someone else.
Maybe it was Pan.
Pan no Mimi.
Or Kaori.
But they were very close.
They were very close.
Who's the artist?
Do you guys mind if I get the doujin?
Hold on.
Let me double check.
I should follow them.
Hold on.
I'm gonna turn this down.
The music doesn't loop as like...
The music needs to be a little bit longer.
Okay, hold on.
Let me get the doujin.
I'm really glad I knew where it was.
Because I...
Um...
Went through some of my...
I went through some of my books recently.
So I was...
I knew.
I knew where it was.
Um...
Shiro Kitsune.
Shiro Kitsune is the artist.
At Shiroro Kitsune.
So at Shiroro Kitsune.
So instead...
Their name is Shiro Kitsune but their ad is at Shiroro Kitsune.
And if you see the daki, it's so...
It's actually maybe...
It's actually maybe the softest daki makura I've ever owned.
It's so...
Type it in the chatment.
Oh yeah, I can do that.
Give me one second.
At Shiroro Kitsune.
There you go.
It's probably the softest daki makura I've ever owned.
And...
Um...
Toki is just so...
She's so cute.
And so sexy on one side.
She...
It's...
One side is her...
Is her...
Um...
Is this playable on PC?
Yeah!
So...
I'm playing it on PC right now!
Um...
It's also...
You can play it on browser too.
One side is Mei Toki and the other side, the lewd side is Bunny Toki.
It's so...
Wait.
Did I get that right?
I think so.
Or maybe they were both lewd sides.
Akane is best girl of all time.
Akane is side boob city, baby.
I'm playing it on PC right now.
So... I checked in both lewd sides.
Whoopsie.
But it's really cute, right?
It's like... and if you can find it, it's so soft.
It's so soft.
Oh, Ako!
Sorry, I was thinking of Ako.
You're so right.
I was thinking of Ako, not Akane.
Asuna got me into the game but stayed for Hina.
Hina's a good girl.
Oh my gosh!
When I was in Japan, they had a Blue Archive Valentine's event at the Akiba and Atore.
And they had Hina's little floatie.
They had her floatie that she has in her bathing suit.
Not uniform.
Outfit!
And it's like this cute cushion.
It's so cute!
Oh my gosh!
It's so, so... it's so cute!
And it's really, really soft.
I like sit on it sometimes and... yeah!
It's kind of a uniform.
It's her school swimsuit.
Yeah!
That's true.
And they also had a t-shirt.
A t-shirt of her... of the swimsuit.
And it's like... you would think that... like maybe it's a shirt that's cotton.
No!
It feels like a swimsuit material.
So I bought it really oversized so that I can just wear it.
And like have my little floatie and pretend that I'm... I don't know... this is my stupid at home cosplay.
My favorite is the stink ball.
Sorry, I mean...
I forgot... I was like playing the other day and I was like...
I was like looking up how to... I couldn't get through a battle.
And... I looked it up and it said to... it recommended swimsuit Ui and I was like... I don't have that!
But I did!
I'm just an idiot.
Anyway...
Majan!
I want to go to the event but we won't.
Because... wait how do I... oh here we go.
I will not go to the event but...
Because we have... tutorials to do.
Chapter 1.
Majan tiles.
Guys, we're gonna learn Majan today, okay?
We're gonna learn Majan today together, okay?
Please help me.
And then we're gonna roll...
Hello?
Oh, here we go.
Then we're gonna roll.
We're gonna roll and then play.
Step 1.
Eat the tiles.
I'm gonna actually also open a notepad so I can take notes.
I'm scared.
Baby Gory thanks for the gifted!
Oh no, how do I say your name?
I'm gonna say Deodato!
Thank you for the five gifted!
How do I say it with the squiggly?
Roll on which banner?
Blue Archive, of course!
Okay.
Welcome to Majan Sho...
Welcome to Majan Sho Shrine!
Are you here for fun times?
Playing Majan as well?
No, I'm here for serious times.
Let's learn the basic rules of Majan first.
Majan has 34 different tiles.
They can be sorted into five groups.
Man, Pin, Sho, Wind, and Dragon.
Man?
Okay, Man is like...
The 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8...
9...
Pin is...
Like a pinwheel.
Sho is...
So tall bamboo.
Wind is...
Is...
East...
Wind is...
The directions that it goes in.
East, South, North, West.
Dragon is...
The dragon inside.
Inside of me.
Inside me there are two dragons.
So tall bamboo.
Okay.
There are four of each tile.
Wait, what do you mean there's four of each tiles?
There's nine.
So in total there are 136 tiles?
Oh, four copies.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I was like...
Can you count, little cat girl?
Sorry, you can't see her.
She's so cute though.
She's so cute.
Sequence.
Three consecutive number tiles.
Okay.
Sequence.
I feel like this is actually going to be on the test.
Three consecutive number tiles of the same group.
Oh, I wrote name group.
Of the same group.
Okay.
So sequence is like...
Three...
Three minds.
Three pins.
Three souls.
Triplet.
Is three...
Three identical tiles.
Okay.
And then pair.
Two identical tiles.
Okay.
We're...
We're making notes.
Easy.
Thank God they have the numbers in the corners.
Oh, yeah.
If you can't read it, it could be confusing.
Right?
Wait.
Okay.
I just realized.
The sequence has to be like six, seven, eight.
Right?
It can't be like four, eight, nine or something.
Like it has to be like three consecutive consecutive.
Right?
So...
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Here.
See the sequence.
Three, four, five.
Seven, eight, nine.
Five, six, seven.
Can I...
Hold on.
I'm going to put my...
I'm not putting on my glasses.
Putting on my glasses for this.
So I can really learn.
Okay.
We're good.
I'm learning.
Don't McDonald's say no.
NERD!
DON'T SAY NERD!
Is she rolling for Hoshino?
I'm rolling for...
everybody.
Because I like all of them.
All the... everybody that's in the collab at least.
I'm so bad.
There's so many girls.
I'm really bad at remembering a bunch of names.
If you say somebody and I'm like, who?
It's because I'm bad with the names in Blue Archive.
Okay, four sequences...
Okay, wait.
Okay, so four sequences or triplets...
plus one pair equals winning!
Winning!
Okay, so pair is too identical.
Or a triplet.
Four sequences or triplets...
plus one pair equals winning!
Winning!
This game is like poker but tiles instead of cards.
You know what?
I never could understand poker either, so...
NERD!
Says you!
With your silly...
ducky hoodie!
Come on!
The main objective of Mahjong is complete a winning hand.
Usually it means the player has to achieve a hand consisting of...
four sequences slash triplets plus one pair.
To reach that goal, each turn you draw one tile...
from the tile wall.
And if it's not the winning tile, you choose one tile to discard and maintain...
a hand consisting of 13 tiles.
Step by step, you will get closer to a winning hand.
Okay.
NERD!
Who's hand was that?
Oh my god.
Here, let's discard the west tile that's unneeded here.
Yeah, we don't need this one.
That's my hand.
Okay.
In addition to the tile group requirement to win...
the winning hand must also contain at least one yaku.
What's a yaku?
Simple yaku.
Wait.
Huh?
Wait, the text is so...
Oh, I have to scroll?
I have to scroll to go through the text?
Huh?
No yaku.
Yaku equals win conditions.
It's a valid hand.
Of course it is.
So...
I want to introduce a really popular and easily achievable yaku.
All simples.
Also called tanyao.
If your hand only has number tiles with numbers from 2 to 8...
In other words...
Does not have honor tiles...
Wind or dragon tiles...
Or terminal tiles...
Number tiles with 1 or 9...
Then it meets the requirements for all simples.
So let's try it out.
Okay, so no 1s or 9s...
Okay, hold on.
Yaku...
No 1 or 9...
No wind...
No dragon...
Hmm...
What's this one?
Why is it just blank?
It's like...
Who?
Who is this?
Okay.
So just...
Anything else?
Just say 2 through 8.
Yeah, yeah.
2 through 8.
Good.
What's 4 doing all the way over here?
Hmm...
Oh, white dragon.
Okay.
I...
I don't know...
Okay.
Hold on.
We already have 1 triplet.
Yes, right here.
This is our triplet.
The...
The 2s.
Sorry, I'm blocking a little bit of it.
2 sequence.
6, 7, 8.
Here.
And 1 pair.
Wait, what's the pair?
2 identical tiles.
Here!
Here's our...
Here's our pair.
So, once we have completed the last sequence, we have a winning hand!
And it meets the requirement for all symbols.
Get rid of you.
When your hand is waiting for the winning tile like this, you are in Tenpai.
If you have Yaku and are in Tenpai, you just need someone to discard the last needed tile or draw it yourself to win.
Wait, why discard the last needed tile?
Am I allowed to take their tiles?
Yeah, we have double here.
So, we need a...
So, we have triplet.
1 sequence.
2 sequence.
Oh, wait.
Hmm?
Wait.
I have a question.
If it's...
So, is it 4 sequences?
Okay, if I have 2 sequences and 2 triplets, is that...
Is that okay?
Mahjong is easy.
Don't worry about it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes?
That's okay?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Yes.
Plus the pair.
So, it's just 4 sets in total.
Okay.
Let me write that.
In...
In total.
So, 4...
So, okay.
So, we have 1 triplet.
1 sequence.
1...
2 sequences.
So, we need...
And then...
And then a pair.
So, we need either a 3 or we need 6.
Okay.
So, that'll make 3 sequences and then 1 triplet, which is 4 in total.
Oh my gosh.
I can do math.
I'm...
I'm adding.
Addition.
Subtraction.
Multiplication.
Okay.
Give me...
That's the tile we...
Tile we need.
That one right there.
We can win now.
Tap the run button.
Run.
This is going to take my brain into overdrive.
Holy cow.
Congratulations on the win.
Yeah.
This is the end of today's practice session.
You can review the tutorial by chapter or just check out the review.
Thank you.
And I'll see you guys later.
Peace.
Yippee!
Give me the coins.
The copper.
Is that how we do the gacha?
Hold on.
I kind of wanna check.
How do we do the gacha?
Why not take a breather and check out a festival at another school?
Oh.
Following the recent upheaval at Abidos High School, Shiroko and Hoshino followed Sensei's advice and took a bus to Aleid Hyakugan.
Hyakkiyako Academy for their festival.
Or at least that's what they thought they were doing.
Gatcha needs premium currency.
No!
Oh my gosh.
This doesn't look like Hyakkiyako Academy.
Wait, there's a whole story even?
Shiroko stared at the school in front of her with a blank expression.
Next to her, Hoshino yawned unconcernedly.
Clearly, we're in the wrong place.
Look, the pillar over there says this is Asaha High School.
Is it Allied?
Allied?
And it was shaping up to be such a nice day.
Even you dozed off for a bit, Shiroko.
I thought we were at Allied.
Allied Hyakkiyako Academy.
I'm sorry.
I should have paid more attention.
to the name of the stop.
I'll go see you when the next bus arrives.
Give me the gatcha.
We want to go to a school festival.
Here is just as good as anywhere.
Why are Abito students at Neo Japan High?
Looks like they're having a festival too.
Why don't we go in and have a little fun?
Look, she must have been late for school.
She's got her toast in her mouth and everything.
If you're sure, then I guess it would be okay.
I'm sure.
Shall we?
What a coincidence.
The problem solvers are here.
They're so cute.
Look at them.
Shiroko is so cute.
There was the Blue Archive like...
What's the word?
The Blue Archive...
anniversary festival thing?
And they sold her scarf and her...
and her ears and her...
little hair pin.
And I bought all of it.
Just as Hoshino and Shiroko approached the gates, they heard a voice call out from behind them and turned to see two familiar figures.
President Riko Hachimaru and Asagi Mutsuki.
Members of Gehenna Academy's infamous Problem Solver 68.
Known as the Outlaws of Kivotos.
Their four-member team is so close-knit that they've been known to happily split a bowl of ramen between them.
They are the inheritors of the masked swimsuit gang's legacy and build themselves as reliable and trustworthy...
Oh, sorry.
Reliable and trustworthy when it comes to fulfilling some rather dubious contracts.
Good morning, friends of Abydos High School.
Good morning.
Were you also summoned here?
Summoned?
Lore dump.
Yeah, split the ramen bowls for bonding.
No other reason.
No.
No, it's not like...
Oh my gosh, look at the tummy detail on Aru.
Just a rumor I heard.
It's nothing.
Did Asaha High School hire you?
Yeah, we got a last-minute call yesterday.
Tough job.
Nothing Problem Solver 68 can't handle.
We never leave loose ends.
Cuckoo.
How very professional of you.
Hehe.
I make us look so good.
Aru.
She looks so cute.
Oh my gosh.
They look so good.
Aru prefers big jobs.
But actually, things have been pretty slow lately.
We don't have the luxury of being choosy about contracts right now.
Mutsuki's naughty face, I know.
Are you two just here to hang out?
Yes.
Sensei suggested we should take some time to relax and check out another school's festival.
Oh, that sounds nice.
Ahem.
It's getting late, Mutsuki.
And we shouldn't keep our client waiting.
It's bad business.
If you'll excuse us.
Aru flashed a perfunctory smile and set off towards the school.
Mutsuki waved goodbye to Hoshino and Shiroko and followed.
perfunctory...
I don't know much of Blue Archive, but I think I've seen that blue cat at the bank before.
How could you tell from her disguise?
Happy Bunch Art Day.
Shall we head in too?
Sure.
So the Foreclosure Task Force and Problem Solver 68 joined the festivities inside Asaha High School.
Asaha High School is holding a school festival with lots of fun activities and delicious food, nya!
Oh my gosh, it's a bop!
But they are short on manpower, so they ask if Master can help out with approving proposals, nya!
Ichiyun-hime has already said yes and ate the pudding, so Master can't say no, nya.
We are number one!
I hear it.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to unhear it.
nya nya!
We already got a proposal here!
Master, let's tap on this proposal and check out the content, nya!
I propose we forbid Ichihime to take part in the festival.
She already has cleared the stock of the snacks, nan.
At the school gate.
Strongly agree.
M-Master, don't take this prank seriously, nya!
Anyway, when you approve a proposal, the three fest stats will change, nya.
There's mashups of the two!
I can believe it.
When the fest stats meet the rank up requirement, the fest rank will go up.
The current rank is E-, so we still have a long way to go.
But I'm sure Master can do it, nya.
The good news is that Master won't be working alone, nya.
A few special guests have arrived at the festival, and they will help you out, nya.
Let's go meet them now.
Nan- Hold
on.
How do I pull them?
How do I get them?
Tutorial.
During the festival...
Level up.
Confirm.
To the shop?
Where do I pull them at?
Oh, shop.
Wait, they have...
They have their own outfits?
Shi-shi-shi-shiroku!
Oh my god.
You haven't gotten this character yet.
Not yet.
Oh my god.
Shi-shi-shi-shiroku!
It's so cute.
Wishing.
Star.
Look how cute.
The art is all so cute.
Fortune.
Background.
It says first, then money for skins.
How do I...
Wait, so the shop is...
Is it summon?
Ah!
Here we are.
Uh oh.
Let's learn how to...
Wait, what's the difference between bamboo club...
and sakura club?
Let's learn how to play first.
The more I play...
Because, you know, I don't want to just spend money on them and be like, Man, I hate mahjong.
Let's keep doing the tutorials.
Yeah, let's keep doing the tutorials.
Oh, here's the yak.
I hate mahjong.
Bamboo has men.
Oh wait, sakura has other female characters.
Bamboo has male.
Oh no.
Okay.
Thanks for letting me know.
The red mark on the table has moved.
It means the dealer seated east has changed.
This is an east wind match.
So the match ends when every player has been dealer one time.
Don't think of running away before the match ends.
When the match ends, the four players will be ranked from first to fourth.
Do your best to aim for first place.
The east two in the center indicates that the match is the second game of the east wind round.
East wind is the current prevalent wind.
X69 indicates the number of tiles remaining.
If this number becomes zero, then the game will end even if no one wins.
Okay.
What does the prevalent wind mean?
The W in front of you indicates you are seated west in this game.
And west is your seat wind.
It's a lot to take in, but it does make sense.
Eventually.
Yeah, we're in the W spot.
A triplet of prevalent wind and a triplet of seat wind are both very common yakus.
Oh, that's right.
They said the...
Okay, so there was the yakus, which is...
Which is...
Two through eight.
So this is also a yaku we can have, right?
Yakuhai.
So a triplet of a seat wind.
Okay, hold on.
Yaku.
One.
Yaku two.
A triplet of prevalent wind.
So the prevalent wind would then be...
Okay, east wind round.
Oh, so it's because...
Wait, is it east wind?
Wind round because it's east and I'm sitting west?
Wait, no.
Oh, never mind.
Sorry.
I was confusing wind and west.
Weast?
I mean, wait.
What?
East?
I thought you meant weast.
Okay.
Now it makes...
Okay, I was thinking east west round, but it's east wind round.
Okay, that makes so much more sense.
What's the two for though?
And we are sitting west.
So we can either get the prevalent wind or we could get our seat wind.
Prevalent wind.
Oh, wait.
And a triplet of seat wind.
So you need both?
Okay.
If you get three west tiles, then you can win with seat wind.
West as Yaku.
Oh, it's either or?
Because it says here and.
A triplet of prevalent wind and a triplet of seat wind.
Oh.
So, okay.
Or.
Triplet of prevalent wind or triplet of seat wind.
Both are Yakus.
You can get both.
Either, either, either.
Read the whole sentence?
I did.
You can't say that to me when I literally read the whole sentence.
I literally just confused wind for west.
Okay?
My brain is small.
My glasses are the wrong prescription.
If any other player discards a tile and you have two tiles of the same kind in your hand, you can call Pon to form a triplet.
Upon calling Pon, you shall openly place the triplet formed in the corner of your table.
Don't miss this tile.
Pon!
Pon-ya!
After you called Pon successfully, discard one tile from your hand.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye tile.
What the hell was this one?
If the player on your left discards a tile that can form a sequence with two tiles in your hand, you can call Chi on that tile.
Upon calling Chi, you shall openly place the sequence formed in the corner of your table.
Wait, what did they place?
The six?
Wait.
On my left.
Oh, hold on.
I need to read this again.
Pon and Chi can mess up your hand if you aren't careful.
Okay.
Go to settings and turn on the tile numbers.
Easier for a while.
Yeah, I will do that.
I didn't know...
I thought it...
Because it showed it before, I thought it would stay, but it does not.
Wait, okay.
So the player on my left discards a tile that can form a sequence with two tiles, then I can call Chi.
Okay.
Only from left hand player.
From any player.
I see.
Sometimes you don't want to call Chi, but you don't understand the bigger hands in it.
Yeah, I don't know anything.
Chi.
Chi-nya.
After you call Chi successfully, discard one tile from your hand, too, nya.
Okay.
What is that?
Goodbye tool.
Now you've reached tenpai.
What was tenpai again?
Oh wait, it's when we have a hand but we're waiting for one thing, right?
When you draw one pin or four pin...
...yourself or someone else discards either tile, you win.
Yeah, one tile from winning.
Ready to win.
Okay, okay, I kinda remember.
Confusing kanji at the bottom is man.
It is?
This one?
Okay.
Okay, so I need...
So they say one pin.
So we need the pair, right?
Because we have...
Okay, sorry, I'm gonna be explaining everything out so slowly for me to learn this.
So we have...
Three...
Wait, we have...
We have a sequence...
And we have...
Our prevalent...
Wind.
Okay.
So now we just need...
Wait...
So we need...
Either...
We have a...
We have a sequence here.
And we have a triplet here.
One, two...
Three...
So then...
If we get...
This is a pair...
Or this is a pair.
Why couldn't we...
Oh, because then it will break the sequence.
Okay.
I get it, I get it.
So this becomes a sequence.
Or like...
This becomes a sequence if we get the four.
Or this is a sequence...
This is the sequence if we get the one.
Okay, okay, okay.
Maybe some of us are learning together.
So...
This is kind of good, maybe.
Okay.
So that would make...
The yaku...
One, two, three, four.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
We got...
This!
Wait, if you have four of the same tile...
You can type kan.
And these tiles will be placed in the right corner.
And you get to draw one tile...
And then discard one tile.
This is called a closed kan.
And the quad formed here is considered...
A kind of triplet.
Oh, oh, okay.
Closed kan!
It's a shame that we didn't win with the drawn tile.
Let's discard it.
See ya.
Okay.
Oh, oh!
Non!
Nom, nom, nom, nom, nom, nom.
Yippee!
We won the tutorial!
Oh my gosh.
I feel like I'm in...
Kaiji just a little bit more.
Congratulation on the win-ya!
This is the end of today's practice.
You can review the tutorial...
Okay.
Woohoo!
Zawa, zawa, zawa, zawa.
Okay.
Let's get our money.
Copper...
Michi!
Okay.
Zawa, zawa, zawa, zawa.
Oh yeah, go to option.
Thank you for reminding me.
Um...
Under...
Oh, uh, this one.
There we go.
Perfect, perfect.
Next tutorial.
Oh wait, oops.
Michi.
You could say nonsense...
and I'd believe it was a mahjong term.
The only thing I really knew was...
Don.
I only really knew about the...
But I didn't know what it meant.
At all.
Now I know what it means.
It means I'm gonna take your tile.
In the upper left corner, there are five tiles.
But only one is revealed.
Isn't that strange?
I knew yaku, but I didn't know what it meant.
Michi is the best because you don't have to do anything.
Once you're in that state.
Oh...
Yeah, no Niko's win by...
stealing the tile.
So...
I have a question.
Can you only...
Don if you're in the...
What was that?
What was that state called?
Tenpai?
Yes, you need to beat Tenpai.
Okay.
I'm gonna write that down.
Can only Don...
tile from...
another person...
win in Tenpai?
I need one more tile...
to win.
Okay.
My notes.
My notes, my notes, my notes.
If not, it's just a Pon.
Or Chi.
Okay.
If not, it's Pon or Chi.
Wait, okay.
So Chi is...
taking from the left.
From...
person on left.
What was a Pon again?
I don't remember.
Wait.
The game will let you make...
wrong calls.
That's okay.
Being in Tenpai is like Uno...
in Uno.
How?
Okay, okay, okay.
Pon is for calling triplets.
Ah, okay.
Pon...
for calling...
triplets.
When you have...
two of a tile and someone discards the third.
Okay, okay.
Okay, thank you.
Taking...
Okay.
Okay!
And Chi is for taking...
from the person...
The Chi is for sequence.
But only for the...
Taking from the person on the left.
But only for sequence.
So you can't do Chi for...
Okay, so if I take from the person on my left...
and it's for a triplet, it would just be a Pon.
Chi is for sequence.
And you can only take from the person before you.
Pon is for triplets.
You can take from anyone.
Ah, okay, okay.
You don't have to worry about the left side thing...
in this since it won't let you.
But it's still good to know in case I play...
outside of...
Mahjong Soul, right?
So...
It's gonna be confusing...
at first.
Yeah, but that's okay.
I think I'm already...
understanding...
slowly.
I'm getting...
I'm knowing...
I'm understanding...
better than I did before when I tried.
The best advice I have about Mahjong...
is to avoid calling tiles until you recognize...
the Yaku...
that you're building.
Wait, what do you mean by calling tiles?
By putting them over here...
on the right side of me?
Over here?
Good advice.
By calling...
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm gonna write that down.
Calling tiles...
equals taking tiles.
Stealing tiles.
Becoming...
a criminal...
of tiles.
Okay, cool.
So, in that regard...
it feels like poker.
Aren't you supposed to hide your hand...
in poker for so long?
Crimes.
Crimes!
I didn't know so many...
Vtuber fans knew how to play Mahjong.
I've always been...
so fascinated when I go to...
like an anime convention because there's...
without doubt, always a group of...
people that are just playing Mahjong.
Like somewhere on the floor.
So...
I've always been...
so fascinated to try...
and learn how to play.
Because it seems fun.
If it's so fun that...
there's people that are just like...
sitting around playing Mahjong.
There are at least four of us.
I've never seen that.
That's crazy.
Really?
I feel like I've always seen it.
I have a set I bring to furry cons.
No way!
How do you hold them in your furry paws?
This is where mind games come in.
If you're calling tiles, it also makes it more likely...
to let the other players figure out what hand you have.
Yeah!
That's where, like I said, where it feels like poker.
Also, hi, Emily!
Oh god.
I should watch Saki.
I should finish Saki.
I saw a group of...
Zombieland Saga cosplayers playing Mahjong.
Okay.
This is the Dora.
Oh my gosh!
D-d-d-d-d-d-dora!
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-dora!
Dora, Dora, Dora!
She's a gambler!
Dora!
Oh my god, she got into Mahjong!
Oh my god, boots!
She sold boots off to pay off her debts!
Dora the Mahjong...
Dora the gambler.
They will indicate the shining Dora tile.
The tiles...
Wait, the tile next in order after the revealed indicator tile is Dora.
If the one man is revealed...
Oh, that scared me.
Then the two man in your hand is Dora.
Huh?
Swiper knows so I pick credit cards.
Wait, what?
Soy gambler!
Hola!
Okay, this confused me the most.
Shiny tiles equals more points, basically.
Okay.
Dora is the next tile from the revealed tile.
Shiny tiles equals bonus points.
Ah!
So if I have...
But this one's shiny.
Two.
The tile next in order after the revealed...
Oh, so because this is revealed, then this would be the shiny, the Dora.
Sorry, not the...
It's Dora.
Okay, okay, okay.
Is it just in my hand or...
So if you're like trying to really big brain it, you would want to get like a sequence with the Dora...
With Dora or like a triplet Dora or something like that.
Dora's are for everyone.
Okay.
So if one is revealed, then two is Dora.
Ah!
Okay, okay, okay.
The more Dora, the better.
Yummy points.
Okay, okay, okay.
You guys are so helpful today.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you guys.
When you win, the more Dora tiles you have in your hand, the more points you win.
Oh, I didn't even...
It's not even letting me put anything down.
It's like you're still too stupid, okay?
Oh, another Yaku.
Another Yaku is Ritchie.
Ritchie.
Okay.
When Ritchie is possible, the following button will appear.
You need to pay 1,000 points as Ritchie bet.
Ritchie is best Yaku.
Okay, when you have neither all symbols nor triplet of prevalent seat wind, what can you do?
Since we haven't called T or Pon yet, we can call BT.
It's also a very common Yaku.
Okay, so I don't have all symbols
nor triplet of...
Okay.
It's the lock-in button.
When Ritchie is possible, the following button will appear.
Wait, call is not allowed.
Because this is the triplet of the prevalent or seat wind.
Because it's east wind and I'm sitting west.
Right?
So...
That's why I can't call the Ritchie.
Because I have to have neither all symbols
nor triplet of prevalent seat wind.
The Ritchie button is so satisfying to press.
Once you're Ritchie, you can't T or Pon...
Or what?
Magi, was you right?
Hello, my favorite vegetable introduced me to your lives and I'm enjoying it.
Can you send a hug to Lucas for me?
Please.
Hugs from Brazil.
Thanks, Roy.
Hi, Lucas.
If you feel a chill, it's me.
Thank you.
The game will play itself once you go into Ritchie.
Oh, really?
Okay.
I'm just gonna keep going.
Tap the Ritchie button, pay 1000 points as Ritchie bet and discard a tile to make your hand Tenpai.
Okay.
So hold on.
Let's see why this makes it Tenpai.
So we have a sequence.
One sequence.
Two sequence.
A triplet.
Um...
So, that's three.
Thanks, Takizo!
You can reach it as long as you haven't stolen any tiles that round.
It doesn't have to be all simple.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
And then we have four pair.
So, um...
All we would need is another sequel.
We didn't need a five or an eight, right?
Hmm.
So that's why we get rid of this.
Okay.
Ritchie-nya!
While paying 1000 points is a pain and you can't change your hand after calling Ritchie, you will have Ritchie as Yaku and you only need to draw a tile and discard it until you win!
But I can't steal.
So I have to be lucky.
I win!
Ippatsu-zuma!
Okay.
Ippatsu is a Yaku that comes into effect if the player wins within the next turn after declaring Ritchie, i.e.
before their next discard, without interruptions from other players' calls.
Oh my gosh.
Friendinator!
I think you're the Akasuba!
It's dangerous to gacha without money.
Here, take this.
No!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
As a reward for winning with Ritchie, you also get the chance to have another Dora coming into effect.
Let's check out what the Uradora tile is.
Tsumo.
Hidden Dora.
We had no...
We had no hidden Dora though.
Tsumo-nya!
No Uradora.
Too bad.
Yippee!
It's a pity we didn't have any Uradora tiles in our hand.
But even like this, we win with bigger winning points since we have both Ritchie and Ippat.
Okay.
Congratulations on the win-nya!
This is the end of today's...
Okay.
Okay, so Ippat...
I didn't write anything for Ritchie.
Wait, I wrote no notes for Ritchie.
Okay.
Can call when you uh...
haven't called Chie or Pon.
Like,
Ritchie is just click it if you see it.
But like...
And then Ippat is win after Ritchie.
Thank you.
Ippat win after...
Win right after calling Ritchie.
But...
And all...
No all-samples or wins.
And...
So...
I'm kind of confused.
What's like the...
What's like the benefit of calling Ritchie?
Oh, it's just a Yaku.
Ritchie is riskier but worth more points.
Okay, okay, okay.
You don't need any other Yaku.
More Yaku is more points, so it can stack.
Oh...
Ritchie is a Yaku easy to get because game is called Ritchie Majong.
I see.
If you win with Ritchie, you'll be rich.
A friend...
My friend asked me how much I had to get you to play Majong.
I'm so glad my Kamiyoshi is finally playing one of my favorite games.
Nice!
Thanks, Nicholas!
Help me out, then.
Thank you.
You can only get Uradora... Oh, okay.
Only...
You can only get Uradora if you win with Ritchie.
Let me write.
Uradora equals bonus point shiny special tile.
You can ignore all other Yaku, so very beginner friendly.
Okay.
You're a certified grandma now after this?
I still have... I still have one more chapter.
And then I got to...
I got to do the test, which I'm really scared for.
Okay.
Oh, you're awake!
Did I die?
I have played the game halfway for you, nya.
Check out your hand.
We have so many man-tiles, nya.
Sorry, this hand looks a bit weird.
Okay.
Simply Yaku half flush.
Is this the...
Wait, what was it called?
Like a...
Honnitsu.
She's sabotaging you.
I'm afraid it's been nine years.
Look at your arm.
No!
Bro, if these are simple, what's a complex Yaku?
For real though, right?
Okay.
May only contain numbered tiles of one suit and triplet or pair of honor tiles.
Can only contain numbered tiles of one suit and triplet or pair of honor tiles.
So the honor tiles are the...
The...
The dragon one, right?
Right?
Uh...
Dragons wins.
Wind and Dragons.
Okay.
Mmm.
While it is worth 300 after you make a call, the worth will be...
You're...
Okay, this hand is aiming for a yaku called Half-Flash, where aside from honor tiles, all the numbered tiles belong to one suit.
Currently, we're waiting for 1, 4, 7 man.
Oh my gosh, 1, 1, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Making this a very advantageous hand.
But why are we waiting for the 1 or the 4 or the 7?
Wait...
13 orphans.
Sounds scary.
Oh, I can't... I'm looking at this like it's my hand.
I'm a dummy.
Sorry, sorry.
Okay, yeah, you're right, you're right.
We can't... okay, okay.
Yes, down here.
Down here is our hand.
Okay.
It's a meme hand, 13 orphans.
But as we discarded the 1 man before, that means we are in Tempest.
Waiting for tiles including the one that was discarded before by ourselves.
This status is called Discard Furiten.
Okay, so yeah, we're waiting for 1.
5, 6, 7...
When 1 is in Furiten, they can only win by Tsumo.
Okay, hold on.
When in Furiten, you can only win by Tsumo.
And not Ron.
Calling on another player's Discard.
I'm just... I feel like, you know when you take notes from a class and you just type exactly what was written on the PowerPoint that the teacher had on the board?
That's how I feel right now.
Furiten is bad, basically.
Okay, aside from Discard Furiten, there are also 2 other types of Furiten called Temporary Furiten and Ditchi Furiten.
But I won't go deep into these here.
Thank you.
Oh, goodbye.
Girl, we can't wait for the other 3 players to discard any of the winning tiles on this situation.
Try to draw the winning tile on your own.
Believe in yourself.
That's a win by Tsumo for you!
Good job!
Tsumo-nya!
Yippee!
It's not like it was a tutorial or anything.
So... so if I... if I were to have won by Ditchi...
Wait... no.
If I were to have gotten... used these... the soul... the soul tiles...
The 3 soul tile would have been the Dora, right?
Raiders?
Hi Raiders!
Hello!
My name is Mint Phantom and right now my brain is leaking out my ears.
Thank you!
Thanks for the raid!
Raymak, thanks for the 5 gifted!
If you won by Ditchi, you would have gotten 1000 more points minimum.
And then we could have also maybe gotten the hidden Dora.
My brain... I'm only playing this game because I like Blue Archive, you guys.
Taki, thanks for the gifting!
Thank you!
3 soul would be the Dora, but not usable in your hand.
No, no, no.
Not usable in my hand.
Okay.
That's why I was saying, if I had Ditchied...
Then that would have been... I'm just...
Applying what I learned in the last episode.
Okay...
Murphy, thanks for the 5 gifted thing!
Money!
Okay, let's go over what we learned.
Oh, hi there, new player.
My name is Ichihime.
Never played Mahjong before?
Oh well, let me teach you then.
Okay.
34 different tiles.
So we have the Man.
We have the Pin.
We have Soul.
Let's see if I remember.
Man.
1 man, 2 man, 3 man, 4 man.
Okay.
We have Pin.
Which Pin will...
Miss Mel-chan, thank you for the 5 gift!
Thank you!
If you don't memorize the numbers slash wins, everyone will think you're a scrub.
I am a scrub!
I don't know what I'm doing!
So, 1 man, 2 man, 3 man.
Then you have the Pin Whales.
Then you have the So Tall Bamboo.
Then you have the Wins.
Because Win goes in East direction.
Win goes in South direction.
Win goes in West direction.
Win goes in North direction.
Then you have the Dragons.
The Dragon...
There are 2 Dragons inside of me.
Everybody understand?
The objective of Mahjong is to win, of course.
So how do you win a game?
In a game, each player usually has 13 tiles in hand.
No.
But there are 3 Dragons.
There are 3 Dragons inside of me.
There's...
No.
Okay.
This is what...
See.
This is the kind...
This is the...
This is Naka.
So inside.
So then you have the Dragon.
And then you have the...
Who?
Dragon.
Is it weird that I'm kind of super invested in you learning Mahjong now?
You have...
Then you have...
Who?
Who is...
Who is that?
I mean...
Nice memorization.
Thank you.
Discard the Dragon you don't want.
Oh, sorry.
Not the Dragon.
Discard the card you don't want.
And we have to get certain conditions.
In every turn, you will draw a tile.
So the number of tiles becomes 14.
And you shall discard one from your hand.
Why am I yawning?
I had coffee.
We have to...
Okay.
Before explaining how to win, first understand 3 terms.
Sequences.
Triplets and pairs.
First we have pairs.
Two identical.
Then we have triplets.
Three identical.
And then we have a sequence.
Three consecutive tiles of the same group.
Easy peasy.
This one...
This part's easy.
Yeah.
5, 6, 7.
So tall bamboos.
7, 8, 9.
People...
Oh.
7, 8, 9 people.
That's a lot of people to eat.
And then 4, 5, 6.
Pinwheels.
Usually when your hand consists of 4 sequences or triplets plus 1 pair, you are ready to win, master.
Of course.
In Meetsy Mahjong, you must satisfy other conditions to declare a win.
We will cover them later.
So we have to get 4 sequences or triplets, so we can have 1 sequence, 3 triplets, 2 triplets, 2 sequences.
But we also need a pair.
And other conditions.
This is the most important sign.
Yeah.
You can also do 4 sequences or 4 triplets.
Yes.
You can do 4 sequences or 4 triplets.
Thank you.
Yes.
Yeah.
The other conditions are the yaku.
So there's...
So far, I know 4 different yaku.
4 yaku.
5 yaku.
Of course your hand also often consist of 13 tiles only.
So, you need 1 more to win.
When you just need 1 more tile to win, this hand is called Tenpai.
Tenpai is a necessary step before winning.
So make sure you pay attention to it.
So the...
So if we have 4, 5...
If we get 6, then we would win.
Because we would have these 3 sequences.
Triplets.
And this would make another...
Or we could get a 3.
We could get a 3 or a 6.
And then that would be the pair.
My favorite yaku are all pairs.
Easy to remember.
That does sound easy.
Okay.
That's correct.
7 pairs is a yaku too.
Yes.
Wait.
7 pairs?
Really?
Did I learn that one?
It's also a meme hand?
You can make 7 pairs.
7 pairs is bad!
Which tile does the hand need for winning?
Oh!
Let's see.
We got...
We have a pair here.
Of 2s.
4, 5, 6.
We have a sequence.
3, 4.
Probably this 2, right?
1 sequence.
2 sequence.
3 sequence.
2!
Correct!
Statistically speaking, you're close to 7 pairs once you have 5 in your hand.
Which tile does the hand need for winning?
Okay.
Oh shoot.
This would be our pair.
Right?
Yeah.
We need the 3 because we need the pair.
Right?
Yippee!
Yeah!
Okay.
Wait.
Am I dumb?
We don't have...
Wait.
Actually, I don't understand.
No, you're smart.
Oh!
It turns this one into a pair and then 1, 2...
3!
Oh!
This is the pair.
I was like...
I knew that.
The whole time.
I knew that the whole time...
She failed successfully.
Mmm mmm mmm!
Mmm mmm mmm.
Let's see the other pair.
The other pair is...
A winning hand must contain a yaku.
If you achieve 10-5 of no-yaku, a no-yaku notice will be shown.
That's so scary!
That sounds so scary.
Simple yaku.
Yakuhai.
You know, I don't think I wrote these.
Which yaku I'm doing.
So this is the one where you refer to the...
Oh wait, no.
Yeah, this is the one with...
Yakuhai.
The triplets of the prevalent wind or the seat wind.
Or the dragon... yeah, yeah, yeah.
Three dragon tiles or... yeah, or the dragon tiles.
Yakuhai equals three dragons, your seat wind, east wind.
Okay.
All simples.
Oops, all simples.
Okay, yes, this is the... okay, all simples.
Oops.
Oops, all simples.
No-yaku.
There's some yaku cheat sheets you can look up for quick reference.
You might need it because I'm writing all this down, but I'm more of a visual person than anything else, so...
Writing it down might be completely pointless for me.
You must not have any of the tiles below, which is one and nine.
Or any of the winds or any of the dragons.
Okay.
Niichi.
When Niichi is possible, the following button will appear.
And then I have to pay a thousand points.
When you achieve tenpai without calling chi, pon, or kan.
Yes.
Oh wait, I didn't write kan.
I'm going to call chi or pon or kan.
And no simple... wait.
Wait, is it no... no all-simples or winds?
Oh wait, so it's got to be no all-simples and no all-winds, right?
Close kan from your own hand is allowed.
Oh, let me write that down too.
Close kan.
You can have all-simples or winds.
You can!
Okay, I wrote that down.
Maybe I misunderstood.
Okay.
Doesn't matter what you have in your hand.
Okay, okay, okay.
All-winds is a billion points since it's giga rare.
Are you winning, Minto?
I don't know.
Ritchie lets you win even if you don't have anything else.
Okay.
Going on a trip, so I can't watch the stream.
We'll watch the VOD later.
Have fun wrecking your brain in mahjong.
It ate all my brain cells when I played it.
Thanks, Mason!
Thank you.
Which of the following sequence is a yaku?
Yaku?
East?
It's an east game and we're east seat.
So, east.
Correct!
Nice.
Which tile should you discard if you want to achieve...
Tanyao?
For all-simples, you must not have any...
Oh, wait.
We can't have the one.
Correct!
I wish they wouldn't switch between the terminology.
Either call it all-simples forever or call it Tanyao forever.
You know what I mean?
Or at least always put like...
Like Tanyao, parenthesis, simples.
Now that we have learned the tiles and some yaku, let's check out the game interface.
Master, please look at the screen above.
I shall explain to you one by one.
East 1 means that you are the first game of the east wind round.
East is your current round wind.
67 means the tiles remaining.
My points?
Discard tiles?
Discard tiles you don't want.
Or tiles you don't want.
You can call the discard tiles for T-ponkan.
T is the call to complete a sequence.
Chi is when...
Hold on.
Chi is when I call from the person on my left for the sequence.
Chi is a yoink for sequence.
Correct?
Yippee!
Okay.
So yeah.
Last player left side.
Discard a tile from...
Form a sequence with two tiles.
So...
6...
8...
And they drop to 7.
Here the 7-pin discarded by the last player can be used to form a sequence of...
6, 7, 8-pin.
Yes.
Pon...
Is when anybody...
Pon is when somebody...
Anybody...
Places a tile...
Discards a tile...
That I want to steal.
And I go...
Steal!
And then I take it...
For...
Uh...
Okay.
For...
Triplet.
Steal!
Yoink!
Hey guys.
I'm here in the Florida Everglades.
Oh look!
A shiny spider.
Yoink!
A shiny tile.
Full on Konosuba steel.
Yeah.
The steel just like the fear.
Hai.
Hai desu.
Minto desu.
Are you guys watching Konosuba?
The season 2?
Um...
Yes.
Okay.
So that's to make the triplet.
Pon.
This is the call to complete a quad.
Kan can be...
Called on discarded tiles from any player.
Can also make a Kan call when you have 4 identical tiles in your hand.
Or have...
Has a previously melded triplet.
Season 3.
Wait.
What did I say?
What did I...
Did I...
What did I say?
People were...
Oh.
Did I say season 2?
My bad.
Yeah.
I meant season 3.
My bad.
Okay.
So...
People were saying that Kan is not so great.
People...
Is this one...
Kind of...
Only used...
If...
I...
Am...
Desperate?
Oh.
Yes.
I meant...
This season...
Yes.
Season...
I was like...
I don't think I said which season...
Which season number it was.
So...
Yes.
I was meaning...
I was saying like...
Are you watching it this season 2?
As in...
Are you watching it this season...
As well?
Kan reveals more Dora.
Oh.
Does it?
This calls to complete a quad.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me write...
Kan.
I don't think I wrote Kan down.
Kan...
Equals...
Calling...
To complete a quad.
It can be called on discarded tiles from any player.
You can also make a Kan call when you have four cards.
That's the closed Kan, right?
If I call it on the ones that are in my hand?
It's bad at higher expert play.
It's fine at lower mid-level play.
Oh.
Okay.
Kan will reveal more Dora, which might give your opponent an advantage too.
Closed Kan is best for you.
Mm.
Oh.
When...
Identical tiles in the deck.
You can either draw a card in your hand or have a previously melded triplet and then draw the fourth tile.
Oh!
Interesting.
Okay.
Learning the basic hand composition in the Yaku is a lot more simple than it seems at first.
The real challenge is figuring out the scoring.
It might help to watch Saki just so you can see all the Yakuman hands that you'll only get with MC luck.
True.
Kan is the Saki finisher.
This is making me want to watch Saki though.
Which of the following hands can Chi the sixth from the last player?
Chi is...
The...
Oh my gosh.
The sequence.
So, it would be this one.
Correct!
Which snack do you...
You want to have first?
I'm not a snack!
What are you talking about?
Which of the following hands can Pon from another player?
Pon is a triplet.
So, this one.
Yippee!
Okay.
Chi sequence.
Pon triplet.
That's enough of the basic rules, master.
Remember we have learned the tile groups.
Man, Soul, Pin, Wind, and Dragon.
Three simple yaku, yaku-hai.
All simples in BT.
The equation of winning.
Four sequences or triplets plus one pair.
You can practice your skills with AI by creating a private game room.
Or if you are interested in more advanced rules, you can find them by tapping the question mark icon on the top right corner.
I'm going to sleep now.
We did it!
Tutorial!
Oh my gosh, I graduated.
Look at my little hat.
What does this do?
Oh cute!
That's so fun.
Send help, I'm stuck in mahjong limbo.
I can't get out of bronze.
One of my most recent matches I lost in the first draw?
Am I going to be okay?
Okay, I think what I'm going to do...
I think I should do gacha.
And then I will play a game against the AI.
I think I will do the gacha.
And then I will play the game against the AI.
How much is it to summon 10 times?
Purchase... wait, I'm scared.
Is it going to show something?
Hold on.
I'm getting rid of the window real quick.
Oh, okay.
Do you know that in the manga Akagi, there was a single mahjong game that took 20 real life years to finish?
It was all a single night in the manga.
20 years real life?
It's like $40.
Wait, what?
Okay, hold on.
How much is it?
You need 1800.
That's really expensive.
Check your mail for free stuff?
Where's my mail?
Do I have mail?
I don't think I have mail.
Oh, items maybe?
Illustration?
I got this one at least.
Yippee!
I don't think I have anything.
Oh, under the event.
Mutsuki.
Not this event.
The button that says event.
Oh, this one.
I got 500 fest budget.
I have nothing.
No freebies.
They don't even let you do a free 10 pull?
They don't even let you do a free 10 pull.
That's so sad.
Oh my gosh, though.
This is expensive.
And what does it mean, first purchase?
Oh, like the first purchase, I'll get the bonus, but usually I won't get the bonus?
That's so messed up.
Okay.
We'll do two 10 pulls and see what happens.
Is the gacha on this really stingy?
Wait, oh.
I don't think I have my wallet with me.
I think I have to go get my purse.
I have to go get my purse, you guys.
Give me one second.
I'm gonna go get it.
Check the rates?
Where does it say it?
Oh my gosh.
Good luck, man.
Gacha Majang Soul is kind of brutal.
Thanks!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the gacha fun and enjoyment.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Wait, this artist...
I recognize this artist.
Isn't this Bizet's mama?
Isn't this Bizet-sama's mama?
Fuzzy Choco!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
I knew it, I knew it.
Okay.
Pochimama is a character as well?
Wait, can I identify it?
Can I identify Pochimama's art?
It's not this one, is it?
Oh, it's Akasumi, right?
Close but no cigar.
It's not this one, is it?
Second last row.
Oops.
Second last row...
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
I didn't even see this one!
Ah!
The voice by Ho-chan!
My name is Seira.
I need your introduction.
Wait...
I like it.
This one!
Wait...
I'm so confused.
I was like...
I was like, this doesn't look like...
This doesn't look like...
But it's Ho-chan, so it's okay.
I'm so confused.
Wait...
Ah!
I...
I see it now.
Immediately when I saw her, I was like...
I see it...
I saw it immediately.
This artist also looks familiar.
Hmm...
Tange Sakura.
Her name is Morikawa Ayako.
There are so many cute characters!
Gailamando!
For gacha, you might want to hide your screen when clicking the jade to be safe.
I will.
For sure.
Thank you, though, for the reminder.
Hmm...
Looks familiar.
Looks like Senran Kagura.
This one?
No...
I don't know where.
Looks familiar to me, though.
Pochi-sensei always has like those very like...
Very distinctive eyes, which is why I was like looking at these two.
Because Pochi-sensei's eyes are always so sharp, you know what I mean?
Hmm...
Okay, let me go get my wallet.
I'll be right back.
I know where my purse is.
Okay, I'm back.
I'm glad I have savings.
Because...
Um...
PayPal has put a hold on all the money.
So...
I...
I actually haven't had any...
I haven't been able to get any of the money so far that you guys have donated.
I won't be able to get it for three days.
Three months.
So...
Um...
Credit card.
Okay.
I'm gonna hide my...
Ta-da!
Okay.
Purchase.
Um...
I'm gonna get the 1800.
Uh...
It's not gonna like show my...
Okay.
I'm scared.
Put it in my credit card.
I'm definitely...
I'm like triple checking that I'm in my screen.
Okay.
Um...
Warning.
Do not open for three months.
Okay.
I'm so scared.
I don't think you guys can see but I'm still scared.
I'll only...
I'll only unhide it.
I'll only hide once we're back on the normal...
The...
The screen.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Pay.
Close your eyes.
Yeah.
Successfully purchased 1800 jade.
Yippee!
Okay.
Close.
And...
Ta-da!
Okay.
Summon.
Let's see.
I...
I would really be happy with anybody.
Truly.
But if I were to rank them, I would want Shiroko Aru Hoshinomutsuki.
I shouldn't have said that.
I just jinxed myself, didn't I?
My offering to your gacha gods...
Oh my god!
Dangisau noooo!
Don't!
Don't Sakastano please!
Shiroko is so cute.
She is!
Clearly, the solution is Doraemon.
Overload PayPal with money so it explodes the showers here with our donuts.
No!
No, no, no.
Mutsuki at the bottom.
Saj.
It's because...
Shinoko has to be at the top for me because she's my seiyuu-oshi.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for the Tsubas.
I'm just taunting with this money at this point.
Going for PayPal high scores.
I'm requesting your professional opinion on Ichinose Asuna.
Asuna?
Like... Asuna Smile?
I love Asuna.
My offering for the 3-month long Broke Ghost Raids...
No!
Got your tax, get that Aru.
Yeah, the desire sensor has been activated so...
Okay, I'm gonna... I'm not gonna look.
I'm not gonna look.
Wait, actually, how do I know if I got something good, right?
Tap.
Whoa!
Whoa.
I got a teddy bear.
That's not a girl.
Uh-oh.
Purple streaks?
So this is not good.
I got green streaks.
Delicious cookie!
What the hell is all this stuff?
Where's the girls?
Ooh, a lavender tablecloth though.
Winning!
Hard-boiled shot!
What is this?
It's wine glass.
Oh my god, go to the mall stop for gacha.
Hopefully you can get this sooner.
Thank you, please.
Guys, don't feel like you have to...
Please, don't feel like you have to donate.
Please, please, please.
Serio... I'm dead serious, please.
Especially if it's on gacha.
Please, this is dumb purchases.
Don't.
Do not... Do not encourage this.
But I'll cap it, like, maybe $100.
Or two.
Purple.
Purple!
Pyrobug, thank you!
If you can read this, please give Mint money.
Thank you.
This is fine.
Normal dress.
What are all the items for?
Classic painting.
But gosh, keyboard, thank you.
Not encouragement, but yes to...
Oh my god, we got the Shittim!
We got something, Blue Archive!
The blue sky of Shittim!
That's... Okay, actually I'm quite happy about that.
She's undead serious.
She's undead unserious.
That's quite the...
That is actually what it's called in Blue Archive.
The Shittim chest.
Exquisite... Oh, sorry.
Exquisite.
What is this?
Rainbow trail.
Decoration to equip.
And this one!
Binah the Great Snake.
Oh, and this one's also... limited.
Oh, and this one too!
So we did get a few...
We got three of the limited things at least.
Star of Peroro.
Wait, how do I...
How do I equip the thingy?
The Ritchie effects and music are far more fun thing to get in game.
Dorm?
Decoration.
Dome.
Ritchie.
Oh yeah, we have no music, you're right.
Tablecloth.
Oh, it's so pretty!
We didn't get anything else, yeah.
Okay, save.
Nice.
Items can be gifted to characters to bond them.
Oh, you need to get five bond hearts to unlock the character's voice lines for Yaku.
Ah!
Got it, got it.
Arona doko.
I wish, I wish, I wish.
Okay, hide screen.
Hide screen.
Maybe it's worth getting the twenty-four hundred since you get the bonus twenty-four hundred.
Wait, what?
There's a forty-nine hundred one?
Wait, go away, go away.
Oh, there's an eight one.
There's an eighty dollar one.
I didn't even see that.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Defended my PhD dissertation yesterday.
I wanted to say thanks for so many fun streams I watched while prepping.
Good luck with the gacha.
Oh my gosh.
Congrats!
How do I say your name?
Zez... Zezby?
Zezby?
Congratulations!
Oh my gosh, doctor.
So smart.
Sharing some mahjong sans after luck-maxing Aru.
First pull!
Make sure you check your junk for blue items for a free pull.
I already did check, but thank you!
Okay.
I'm not so invested to go in all so quickly yet.
What card did I use?
Thank you!
Okay, this one.
Credit card.
Do I have to put it in again?
I do.
I'm actually...
You know, I could use this on actual Blue Archive.
Am I stupid?
I've... To be honest, I'm spending more on this than I've spent in actual Blue Archive.
Is that kind of crazy?
I'm actually...
Kind of crazy.
Summon!
So this gives me how many...
How many summons?
Wait...
Someone help please...
Fake me!
Totally not for gotcha!
Thank you for the akatsupa.
Super, thank you.
Two... with some left over.
Purple.
I got a bone?
I got a bone to pick with you.
Railgun event is soon too.
It's okay, I have some gemis saved up.
Laser blast.
Got
the petal!
I just forgot that, I guess.
Oh, you're right.
I don't...
It's like... almost enough to do a second one.
Or a third one, I mean.
Are there...
Can the...
Can the game...
Like a... wow, gorgeous dress.
You have terrible luck.
Um...
Yeah, actually, I do.
This is like... It's part of my...
Um...
It's part of my charm.
It's just... It's one of my...
It's one of my charm points.
How...
How bad my luck is.
This is some of the worst I've seen.
Sorry, man.
That's okay.
It's part of my charm point.
That I have such bad luck.
Going to my first Hololive concert tomorrow.
I'm super excited.
Going to be a million times more excited.
If such when you decide to do a concert.
And I can go to that too.
Oh my gosh, have fun though, Pat!
Wait, what's the concert?
Okay.
Um, how much do I need to...
To...
Get...
What is it?
800?
Oh, DreamHack in Melbourne!
Mel...
Melbourne.
The five dollar one.
Six... Okay, you're right.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Five dollars.
To you, my young soul.
Mel...
Melbourne.
Oh, you're going to Melbourne, mate.
I
have like this, um...
What's the word?
What?
No!
Wrong for Robin, no!
Imagine spending money on gacha.
Who would do such a thing?
Also, what have you done while you were still alive to get cursed with such luck?
Um...
Well, actually...
Um, I'm kind of cursed.
Um...
My...
Like, my ghost family were all kind of cursed, you know?
Um...
Wait.
Making sure you can't see it all of a sudden.
Um...
Basically, I have a curse upon my family.
Not the sand.
How did you know?
How did you know it was a sand curse?
How did you know that?
How did you know?
We're psychic.
Sand curses are so common.
Ah, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Classic curse trope.
Ah!
I see, I see.
Yeah, um...
I took a family vacation once.
And, um...
On that family vacation, my mom, she was told not to touch the sand.
And you know what she did?
She brought it home.
And ever since then, my family has been cursed.
My...
My ectoplasm line.
I wonder if it counts as bloodline.
I mean...
I don't know.
Oh my gosh.
Link!
Thank you for the hack.
Apologies for being an enabler.
Oh my gosh.
You guys.
Gacha is too scary on stream.
This is why I never do gacha on stream.
But I was like, it's Blue Archive.
Okay.
Also, I don't...
Is there...
What does this mean?
Is there a pity?
I don't know.
Oh wow!
That's a really high pity.
Holy cow.
Return the sand or suffer my curse.
Oh!
Stop!
Chiron-chan, please.
A wild shiro appears.
Shiro-ko.
Shiro-ko, come home!
I'm not gonna look.
Did I get it?
I got it!
Okay.
You know what?
I'll take it.
Oh!
We got more music.
Path to...
Or not.
We got...
Any music.
Normal dress.
A delicate fanzine.
Diamonds.
Idiot!
Yippee!
The desire sensor...
The desire sensor called it, you know?
I'm glad you got someone.
I know.
The desire sensor was just like, um, mutsuki last.
We'll have you change that... that, um, that perception.
You can always keep pulling.
I do kinda wanna...
I wanna get at least shiro-ko.
Hold on.
I don't know.
Wait.
Do I go to my dorm?
My body's gonna be in that bag.
Let's see.
Um...
Did I get anything here?
I got the music though, right?
We'll try that one.
In the back, we got the perorouzama.
That's the one.
Double-click to use her?
Wait, didn't I... did I not... Oh, thank you.
I don't think we had anything else.
I want to get different hands too.
You can listen to the music here?
You can?
Oh, there it is.
I do...
Maybe play around to reset your luck.
Good plan.
Get that violin.
I can never tell the difference between a viola and a violin.
Oh wait, save?
Why is it so quiet?
Viola is just deeper sounding?
It's so quiet.
You know what?
Okay.
Let's do... Would a friendly match be the one with the AI or...
Wait, how do I play with the computers?
Create room?
Limited.
Thinking time.
I need a lot of thinking time.
Friendly create AI.
Oh, versus AI.
There we go.
Thank you guys.
It's so quiet.
Okay.
So this is my first game.
We're going to play with the AI.
What?
Where's the music?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, okay.
Let's see.
We could get four, five, six.
Oh gosh.
Hold on.
We have five, six, seven.
Yeah.
Three, four.
We have a pair.
Okay.
I'm tossing this.
This is so stressful now.
We don't want these two, though.
And it seems like we're going for the... for the...
Simples one, right?
Maybe.
Maybe a simple would be easiest.
So, get rid of you.
Dang.
We're just getting rid of those.
Maybe this one.
Oh, okay.
Now we have...
Maybe I get rid of one of the five... wait.
We have a pair of four.
So I get rid of the five.
So we have five, six, seven.
Maybe.
Four.
Get rid of the four.
Get rid of four mon... oh, four mon.
Wait, why?
Hold the pins.
Okay, I'll hold the pins.
Four mon.
Okay.
I have to pay attention to what they're... Oh, we have a triplet!
We have a... a triplet.
Um...
Maybe I get rid of the three, then?
Because... I have the triplet.
We're not going for the... the... sequence anymore?
Three bamboo?
Okay.
We're on the same... we're on the same page, everybody!
Good, good, good!
Uh, oh.
Goodbye.
Goodbye, East.
Maybe.
Ah!
Uh...
Hmm...
I don't think we need this one either, too, though, right?
The five... yeah.
Sayonara, dragon inside of me.
Nope, nope.
Toss it?
Okay.
Sayonara, dragon inside of me.
Oh, chi?
Oh!
Wait, should I call it?
Should I do the chi or should I...
Hmm...
Because it's the five man.
No?
Skip?
Okay.
You shouldn't yet.
Don't open your hand.
Okay.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks.
Um...
If I have a... pair.
I have a pair.
Pair, pair.
So goodbye, Six.
Wait.
Um...
Oh.
The Dora... yeah, rip Dora.
It's okay, though.
Did she do it?
I'm scared.
What do I... wait, what do I do?
Wait.
What do I do here?
Oh, I have ten seconds!
Wait, what do I do?
Seven?
What's going on?
Wait, now I'm actually so confused.
Oh, wait, the game is playing for me.
Wait, can I sumo?
Wait, sumo is which one again?
That's the one where you, um...
Sumo?
Yippee!
Sumo is you drew your winning tie.
Oh, that's right.
That's right.
Okay.
When it gets a little fast...
My brain is like can't keep up.
Oh, okay.
My brain... my brain is can't keep up.
Okay, hold on.
Let's see, I have...
Oh, I have a pair here.
Um...
To pair here...
Uh... I'm gonna get...
I need all my notes in... in... in format of pictures.
Oh my gosh.
Um...
Uh...
Tough hand, not gonna lie.
If you hit the R on the side, it will auto-call your win.
Really?
No, I wanna learn though.
Six bamboo.
Get rid of the...
Either toss the 8P or the 6S.
Drop the soul?
Okay.
Skip?
Wait.
Skip.
Skip for now.
Six bamboo people are crazy.
Hey.
Everyone's gonna have their own...
Uh...
Um...
Okay.
Four, six, eight, nine...
Um...
Sa...
Maybe...
Uh...
Wait.
Um...
The two...
I'm looking...
Wait, it's half flush again.
Oh my gosh.
I need more time to think.
Can only contain...
One suit, triplet.
Wait.
100 tiles.
Oh, oh.
Wait.
No.
I don't know what to throw out.
Goodbye.
Shoot.
That was bad.
I should've just picked something.
Oh, we got the six though.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm just...
I'm like half reading my notes.
Um...
Three
dragon tiles.
A prevalent wind.
I'm south.
So...
And we're on...
Well, I could get the east wind, maybe, if I get any more.
Yeah.
Nine man or east?
Really?
The nine man?
Nine man?
Okay.
Yeah.
Nine man or east?
Oh!
She took it.
I don't need the two.
Oh!
Wait.
Um...
Would keeping the west be any good?
What would it...
Drop the west?
Oh, yeah, because I'm...
Yeah, I'm south seat.
Goodbye.
Okay.
Oh!
Two?
Okay.
This is hard.
Maybe...
East is dead?
Oh, because it's...
Oh!
Because they're here!
Okay.
Goodbye, east.
No!
Drop...
You.
There.
Okay.
Wait.
Pon for what?
The two?
Um...
I could get the triplet.
But I can still also get triplet of four.
Um...
I'm gonna skip.
Oh!
I got a seven.
I got a seven!
Ah!
Wait.
So I can get rid of this four.
Right?
So...
Four man and east.
One out.
Toss the white.
Okay.
Oh!
We got eight.
Okay.
I guess...
We'll get rid of the white.
Goodbye.
Bye bye.
Ah...
Goodbye.
Skip.
Never be pon.
Ah...
Oh!
Ah!
Um...
Skip.
Never change.
Oh!
Wait!
We ended up getting the nine anyway.
That's so funny.
But...
Um...
Can you move over to the...?
Oh yeah!
Yeah, give me a second.
Can I pause?
Yeah, I'll move over a little bit so you guys can see.
There you go.
Oh!
Not that.
There you go.
It's not paused?
You can't pause?
8p?
Thank you guys.
I don't know what I would do without you.
I am trying to think for myself.
Goodbye.
I'm not trying to rely on you guys too much.
But also, goodbye!
Dang!
That would have maybe been kind of good though.
5!
Wait, why is it red?
Why is it different?
You got this!
Chie!
Chie, I'm scared!
Dora?
Wait, what does Dora mean?
Hold on, I need my notes.
Oh!
It is shining.
So keep.
Maybe get rid of the 6?
Or...
9 man?
6 or 9 man.
We'll get rid of the 9 man.
I can't.
6.
I said 6 earlier.
I'm going to commit.
I'm going to commit to the bit.
Goodbye.
We don't need...
What am I pointing for?
Oh!
Wait!
Should I for the 8?
So we can get the triple?
Wait!
Skip?
Really?
Never be born?
7 pairs?
Wait, I...
Skip?
Okay, I'll skip.
I trust you guys.
We're going for 7 pairs.
Skip?
Okay, I trust you Chie.
I trust you.
Anything Chie says...
Chie is God.
General rule of thumb for your first discards is non-yakkuhai wins first, then isolated ones and 9s, then yakkuhai.
If you have a pair of any of the above, you should usually keep it.
We have two easts!
Let's go.
We have two 8s.
Let's see.
Now you pwn East.
Okay...
Pwn time.
What should I... toss though?
I can toss the West though.
Can I toss the West?
Drop W.
Okay.
I don't really need... this either.
I will drop three so the nine pin six or nine pin I could drop either of them yeah we'll drop the nine pin we'll
keep a five pin right we have pair here
This is good for sequence maybe.
Okay, let's get rid of the one.
It's your mom.
No.
Skip.
You could have T if you kept one.
Yeah, but...
Get rid of the AP?
Really?
Okay.
Well, I could get 6, 7, 8.
I have no idea what I'm forming.
I'm just playing.
Drop it?
It doesn't help?
Okay.
Skip.
4!
Oh, we have a sequence of 4, 5, 6.
Okay.
A 7 would make 5, 6...
We have 4, 5, 6 though.
So I can draw the...
Or I can...
Wait.
We have 1, 2...
We can drop either one of these then, right?
So let's drop the...
Let's drop the 1.
Because we could do 2, 3, 4.
Oh.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Wait.
Drop the 8?
I guess because we already have other pairs.
And this will make a...
This will make a triple.
Okay.
Or a sequence, I mean.
North.
Go away.
Uh...
We don't...
Need it.
Let's get rid of the 7S.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Toss.
Come on!
Oh, what?
Keep it?
Ah.
Oops.
My bad.
Why would...
Why should I have...
Why should I...
Why should I have kept it?
Just so I know.
It's 1, 3, 5.
You can finish.
Wait.
1, 3, 5 is a thing?
1, 3, 5 shape is good.
Ah.
The 2 does nothing.
Because 2 is more useless right now.
Oh.
1, 3, 5 can be...
Ah.
I see.
You have...
5s.
Wait.
All 5s have a red version too for more points.
Oh.
I see.
We got another 8.
But...
Um.
We don't need it then, right?
So.
Beginner game.
Hahaha.
Yeah.
What?
Who has the East?
Hahaha.
Give me the other Easts.
Okay.
So.
I think I had the 8 before.
Ah.
So I should pawn here.
I should pawn for the East.
Right?
Pawn.
I pawn.
I pawn for...
Oh.
And I discard...
Maybe the 2...
Wait.
The 2-pin.
Yes.
Okay.
I knew.
Woo.
Oh.
Wait.
Uh oh.
Um.
Hahaha.
Ah.
This one.
I need the 2.
Is that what it's showing?
That's what...
Oh my god.
No!
You guys.
The AI...
The AI bested me.
The AI bested...
We started with such a good hand too and the AI bested me.
Hahaha.
Oh.
Ah.
It's even...
Stop saying AI easy.
It's making me so sad.
Hahaha.
The AI is sentient.
No.
You're good.
You didn't feed.
Mmm.
Itihime experience.
Hahaha.
No.
I did get second though.
I did get second.
I didn't lose entirely.
Let's try...
I mean...
Just like...
Just like with my gacha.
The AIs have gotten crazier to be honest.
I believe you, Tia.
Hahaha.
It's just like with my gacha.
I didn't lose entirely.
I still got someone.
Hahaha.
Let me see...
Something real quick.
With my bank.
I had to make some...
I had to buy some plane tickets recently.
So I just want to check how my bank...
How my card looks right now.
Hahaha.
Let's see.
Mmm.
Shits.
I bought with my...
With my miles.
And let's see.
I have...
Enough points.
Hold on.
I can redeem these points on my card.
Redeem.
You guys...
You guys getting a travel card is so awesome.
Umm...
Actually, I'll do this.
I'll do this later.
Haha.
Thanks, thanks.
Bye.
Myoshi is going to starve!
Hahaha.
Uhhh.
No money for travel.
Miles for Gacha.
I don't know when we get the Patreon money.
I don't know actually when they...
When that...
When that happens.
Looking good with them glasses.
Very cute.
Oh really?
You like the glasses?
I don't really like this style though.
Maybe like a round glasses.
I'm so proud of you Mint!
I was so happy to see the HENYA collab!
You're so cute!
I'm so glad to see you happy!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Patreon is first of the month.
Ah okay.
Big round glasses with a swirly pattern on the lens.
Hey that's really nerd then.
That's really nerdy glasses then.
Yeah I'm so glad that I could collab with HENYA too.
It was so fun.
I actually have been thinking so much about Helldivers.
It was a lot of fun.
It was so much fun.
Okay just...
Just a little bit more.
Just like...
I'll do two more.
Two more.
Not two more.
Wait how much do I have to get?
Uh... 18... wait... 18... 18... 18...
Awww...
Maybe if I do... hold on.
If I do like the...
That's 24.
How much do I need?
30...
3600.
I could just do these two and it'll be fine.
Yeah 36.
By the way, Oshifan...
No!
Thank you though.
Thank you.
But... I'll do these two.
I'm not going for the pity.
But I'm really... I am... I've been wanting to learn...
Oh my goodness.
I've been wanting to learn mahjong for so long.
I'm serious.
So... I want to have characters that I like to play with.
Characters that I like...
To go with.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
What character do I want?
I want Shiroko!
I want Shiroko.
This one... I'm getting the other one.
And then that's it.
That's it.
I'm not... I'm not crazy.
I'm not crazy.
Tax... Tax write-off something something.
On-stream content something something.
Um...
Kayoko, please.
She's not in the game!
It's only Aru, Mutsuki, Shiroko, and Hoshino.
I have a poll and another gacha later.
Please soak my common polls.
Oh, I sure am for you, Daniel.
Okay.
Summon.
Shiroko.
No.
I don't... I don't really want Shiroko that much.
You know what?
I don't really... I don't really care.
You know...
Whatever.
I feel like I've learned so much this stream though.
Truly.
Thank you guys so much for helping me out.
Mint, do you play Blue Archive?
Every day.
I play Blue Archive every day.
It sure would be a shame if you got Hoshino.
No way you'll get her.
Surely not.
Give me back.
I don't want Hoshino.
I don't want Aru.
I don't want Shiroko.
I don't want any...
I had a dream the other night where you would turn into a fruit.
Fortunately, it was just a figment of my imagination.
Oh, I got a cat paw.
I got more shittem.
That's actually my whole poll is a shittem.
Thank you, game.
We got the cat paw though.
I am excited about that.
Alexa, play Unravel.
Tell me, tell me.
This... something, something.
Did I get it?
Part of the ocean?
Hoshino!
Hoshino from high school.
I came here when I realized.
Who said that?
Well, let's do it easily.
Oh my gosh.
It's so funny too because recently I was just like, man, I really want to cosplay Hoshino.
So...
This is so perfect.
Who sent that earlier?
That's super chat.
Where are you?
You...
It was me.
Grump!
Grump, you did it.
You saved my poll.
You saved it.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the thank you.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Grump, you were my lucky charm.
You really did it.
You manifested it.
She's so cute.
Now single polls?
Oh, I do have enough for single polls, don't I?
I always forget that's an option.
It's always go big or go home, you know?
We do have a couple though.
Go to shirt icon.
Oh, that's where we can buy the other things, right?
The other skins.
Oh, there's more?
The bond.
Gift.
What's a good one?
So if I do like this one...
She's sleeping on a whale.
Boom.
Richie.
Double richie.
It's so cute.
Bon.
It like  !
That's a nice trick Oh!
It's nice I look always awesome Me too.
Many other cute girls.
So I merelyafley Did I know that this place would be my home,
She is so cute.
She is such an old man.
Robbing a con?
Under the sea?
Under the river?
What are all of these?
There are so many lines.
YouTuber Aura Holstox!
I luck sacked Mutsuki the other day.
Hope you get everyone you want from this banner.
Oh my gosh, thank you for this very very spooky...
Akadono!
Thank you!
Quadruple force!
So spooky, spooky, spooky.
Oh my gosh, look how many there are.
My brain is starting... Wait, Baiman?
Sanbaiman?
Haneman?
Mangan?
What is going on?
There's so much.
There's so... Holy cow.
How many voice lines are there?
Check the Yaku list, please.
How do I find that?
Look at her!
So cute!
So cute, so cute!
Gasha!
Oh...
Uh...
Gasha!
Me too.
Hold on, throw this over here real quick.
How tall is... How tall is Hoshimi?
Oh...
I'm too tall right now.
How tall is she?
Bring back the glasses!
Hold up.
Almost the same height.
145.
Oh, I'm a little taller.
So this should be kind of accurate, right?
Wait, wait, hold on.
How do I do it?
Hold on...
Hold on.
How do I...
There's like a way that I can move my legs.
No, I moved myself too far.
Too small.
Like here.
Chicken wing arms?
What are you talking about?
I can jump, you guys.
Did you know that?
Wink!
Hooray!
I think
it's because I'm a ghost.
Here, let's do one arm up, one arm down.
Kind of like...
Wait, I want to be opposite of her.
Cheese!
Wait, I have to be kind of a sleepy face too.
What was that?
Oh, no, not the sticky keys.
That scared me.
Thank you!
Jump, ghost girl, jump!
Jump like your life depends on it!
Give me ten more jumping jacks!
Yes, sir!
Wait...
One!
Two!
Three!
Four!
She's doing it, she's doing it!
I can beat, hold on.
You know what I'm going to beat?
I'm going to be the spooky ghost haunting Hoshino.
Hoshino.
Why is my gacha luck so bad, Hoshino?
I wanted Shiroko, I even wore her halo.
Hoshino.
You killed her.
Nope.
I didn't kill anybody.
There's my leg, you sticking out.
Now we're facing the same way.
Yeah!
Well, you do have her halo, so she might be dead.
Oh.
No!
She's literally sleeping.
How do I go back?
There we go.
That was fun.
Little photoshoot time, right?
Little photoshoot time.
Sleeping forever.
Why is your sleeve on Hoshino's chest?
What chest?
Her chest.
Her chest, yeah.
Yeah.
Wait, what if I save changes?
Oh!
It moves her to the middle!
Oh, that's so cute, actually!
Wait, so I can move her around however I want?
So if I'm like...
Oh, yeah.
Hoshino's legs.
Pero pero pero!
Click the question mark.
Ah, here we go!
Yeah, someone asked me about the... looking at the yakuza earlier.
All symbols, fully concealed hand, menzenchin only.
Win a hand by tsumo.
Drawing the winning tile at menzenchin, closed hand.
Seat wind.
Oh my gosh.
1, 2, 3.
2, 3, 4.
3, 4, 5.
6, 6, 6.
9, 9!
This looks impossible.
A full flush.
Holy cow.
This seems like something I'm gonna have to really study.
Blessing of heaven, blessing of earth.
Big three dragons.
Wow.
Easier than you think?
Really?
Four concealed triplets.
What is a menzenchin?
Green dragon is not necessary.
Green dragon is necessary in my heart.
A closed hand.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Closed hand, no calls.
These were all the ones that had the different voice lines.
Okay.
Thank you again for the five gifted.
Thank you!
13 orphans is a myth.
What would that be under?
Oh, there it is!
Win a hand with one of each 13 terminal tiles.
Plus any tile matches one of them.
Wait.
Win a hand with one of each 13 terminal tiles.
Oh!
Plus any tile matches one of them.
So it's like opposite.
It's the exact opposite of the simple one.
Because you can only get ones, nines.
And then the...
The directional...
The honorific ones, right?
Hmm...
What does it mean, plus any tile matches one of them?
What does that mean?
It's the pair?
Oh, the nine pair?
Here?
Ah, I see, I see.
Ah, okay, okay.
So...
But it's any tile matches one of them.
So if it's like...
If I have two...
Two wests, it would be fine.
Still any pair of any...
Okay.
Just one pair.
Hmm...
Not all done, not all done.
Oh my gosh!
I feel like I learned so much today.
Oh my god!
I feel like I actually learned so, so much.
Like I feel like...
Maybe I couldn't win any game, but I could at least know a little bit of what I'm doing.
I learned so much!
For real!
I feel like I could...
Now I'm going to watch Saki and I'm going to be like...
Going in with knowledge that I already know, so...
The power of Blue Archive...
It only took Blue Archive to get me to learn...
Oops, I forgot to change this...
To get...
It only took Blue Archive to learn me...
Learn...
For me...
Wait...
It only...
Took...
Blue...
Archive...
For me to learn Mahjong a little bit.
I do want to watch Akagi though.
I have a couple friends that are really into Akagi, so...
Thank you!
I think I know a little bit more about Mahjong now.
Thanks for the stream!
By the way, Arona or Plana?
I think Arona.
I think Arona for me.
She's more my type.
She's very like...
Like very Rem-esque.
You know?
And I love Rem for...
I mean, I love Rem for everything, but like her looks are just so cute.
But I love Plana too.
Plana would never give Blue Albums.
It's fun watching you learn Mahjong.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Who?
Oops.
Haha.
Ho ho ho.
Hee hee hee.
Ha ha ha hee.
How do you feel about Shiroko Terror?
I like her, but I like normal Shiroko more.
Fresh joke.
Very fresh.
There's Mahjong in nearly every Yakuza game?
Oh, then I need to study even more for whenever I play...
For whenever I play...
Yakuza!
Arona.
All Blues, One Gold.
Stop showing my...
Actual polls.
Who's Rem?
Have you read Volume Final?
I have, I have.
Yes, yes.
Will you be streaming your future Blue Archive polls?
Probably not because I play Blue Archive like on my actual phone.
I think I would feel a little naked.
I would feel a little too like nervous because it's like my actual phone phone.
You know?
Like...
It's uh...
I don't know.
It would make me feel...
Like...
Oh my gosh.
What if I...
What if I accidentally like close out?
Then you guys can see...
Everything that's on my...
Well, not that I have...
I don't really have anything on my...
Home screen.
That would be bad.
Um...
I have all my gacha games which are in a folder called Hell.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass!
Wow!
That's...
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
But if I ever get any good polls, of course I'll show you guys or I'll post them on um...
I'll post them on Twitter or something.
I only have three games in Hell.
I have Blue Archive, Toho Lost Word, and Yuru Camp.
Um...
And then I have my Webtoons.
I have...
I can delete this app.
It's a taxi app from when I was in Japan.
I have Meow Tower which is a noob app.
And then I have like social stuff which is like TikTok, Discord, YouTube.
But my screen is actually quite cute because I have it...
I kind of want to show you guys now.
Because...
Um...
But I also have like my location on here like uh...
Like you know, the weather in my town and the time and everything.
But I have pictures of like um...
Of uh...
Like...
I have Arona.
Here.
Maybe I can like screenshot it.
Hold on.
Let me find something that won't be so...
If I...
Okay.
If I screenshot this and then black out everything.
Hold on.
I'll show you guys.
Actually, I'm just gonna delete these apps.
And then I'll show you.
Remove...
Screenshot.
Oh.
Actually, I'll move the other pictures that I have too even though they're on another page.
Okay.
I like really customized my um...
My uh...
Home screen and stuff.
So it's like super duper cute.
Chaka.
Okay.
Everything should be good.
I'm gonna censor out a couple things real quick.
Skip.
Oh wait.
There we go.
Okay.
Uh...
Actually, it's okay.
Because I'm just on Wi-Fi.
Okay.
Let me...
Send this to myself.
How do I send this to my...
Oh.
Here.
I'm proud of my home screen.
It's so cute.
Have you played the Touhou Rhythm game, Danmaku Kagura?
It used to be a mobile game but now it's a PC.
I haven't actually.
Uh...
Let me...
Get this.
Close.
Save.
Okay.
Screenshot.
My screen is so aesthetic but I was thinking of changing it recently anyway so that's why I'm fine with showing you guys.
So like you can set up...
So basically...
See how I like...
There's the pictures.
I have...
Um...
Uh...
It's...
Like you put it in a note app and then you can like set the notes as like a picture like on your screen.
Um...
So I like have it all aesthetic and all set up and cute and...
It's not...
It's not usually like set up like this.
Like the...
The Arona picture is on like the second page of my...
Of my screen but...
Um...
It's usually just kind of like this.
It's so cute, right?
I think I'm gonna redo it for summer.
So...
Meow Tower is so base.
It's so fun!
I play it every day.
Koharu love.
Isn't it cute?
Isn't it like the cutest picture ever?
Yeah.
This is my...
This is inspo for you guys.
Make your wallpaper or make your...
Your...
Your thing so cute.
You use your stylus?
Yeah!
That's why I bought the...
The Samsung Ultra.
I use my stylus all the time.
Especially for Nonograms.
It's perfect for Meow Tower.
It's actually so, so perfect.
I got hooked on Meow Tower after you made it.
I mentioned it on the pod.
Yeah.
Yeah...
138 Notifications SMH.
I don't know actually...
Let's see what most of that is from.
Most of it is actually from line.
because I follow a bunch of like brand accounts online.
So it's just like...
Oh!
This brand...
This like...
This clothing brand sent me a thing.
So it's to be more specific.
Oh, it's mostly from those.
I cannot live without my stylist.
Me too!
I also use Samsung Note.
Let's see.
I'm gonna put this back.
But usually at the top I have like a clock.
And then I also have like a clock widget.
And I also have like one that... what's the word?
Converts the time to Tokyo.
Like one of those.
Actually, where is that?
And I have a weather one.
Which I'm setting up again right now.
This one.
Uh oh, my thing's all messed up now.
Oh well.
But yeah, I love my phone.
I wish I could have gotten the Blue Archive...
The Blue Archive one though.
I'm so sad about it.
Like there was a special edition Blue Archive phone that I couldn't get.
So...
I rotate through wallpapers too.
Too much to keep a unique icon theme.
Really?
I like this one because it's kind of hard to tell but...
Down here...
You see like the different pages?
They're actually heart shapes.
And then when I like...
Um...
My whole thing is like...
All my texts and everything are like...
Um...
I don't have anything that I could like...
I would have to block out like everything.
If I were to show you my texts.
But like it's a theme that like makes everything hearts and cherries.
And it's like a purple gingham theme.
It's super duper cute.
So...
Yeah.
Weee!
The Go app is Go Taxi in Japan.
If you...
I recommend getting that if you...
Well...
If you use taxis.
I only used it a couple times.
Actually I only...
I really downloaded it.
Um...
Because I prefer taking the train.
Because first of all taxis are so expensive.
Um...
But...
Uh...
I used it...
Um...
I only downloaded it closer to the end of my trip.
Because I needed to get a taxi...
Uh...
To the airport.
And...
There were no taxis that would like come to my apartment.
So...
Hmm...
Is hell all your gacha games?
Yeah.
Drop the keyboard theme?
It's just normal.
It's like...
It's so...
It's just normal.
It's relatively easy to get taxis at most train stations though.
Yeah.
But I wasn't close to a train station.
My apartment was quite far actually.
So...
But...
Um...
There was a close-ish train station.
But...
Um...
Oh my god.
Getting my...
Getting my suitcases down the stairs...
Was actual...
I thought...
I almost fell down the stairs at one point.
I thought I was actually going to pass away.
A second time.
I was like...
Oh my god.
I...
I was fall...
I was falling in slow motion.
Very small things.
Welcome to Peppership.
Thank you.
Yeah.
That was pretty bad.
Getting suitcases down to Tokyo Subway is an experience.
I should have probably just...
How many times does Mint have to die?
I probably should have just like...
Kuroneko'd them to...
The...
To...
The airport.
But...
It's fine.
Can't you just phase your luggage to the floor?
I'm a ghost.
Not my luggage.
Haha.
Kuroneko.
It's ah...
It's a...
Oh.
A shipping service.
It's a shipping service.
Yeah.
Laughs at Danny Phantom.
You wouldn't imagine how many things Danny Phantom gets wrong.
That's all good.
I was always too stubborn or too strict.
It's not cheap to use Kuroneko for stuff like that.
I thought you were talking about Ore Imo.
Took the Yohane taxi to the Awashima hotel dock in Numazu last month after I missed the bus and saw it waiting there.
It was a sign.
You know what?
That's the most proper time to use a taxi ever.
That's like the most proper time to use a taxi ever.
Also, I've had to use a taxi when I was out too late at one time and the trains had stopped.
So I had to take a taxi home and the guy...
The taxi driver was so judgmental.
Because he was like...
He was like...
Why did you stay out so late?
You know how expensive this taxi is now?
You could have gotten yourself a good stay.
I was like...
Sir, I need to go home.
It's not my fault.
Bank account mad at me right now.
Please, stop donating.
But it was a time I stayed out for...
I stayed out because I went to see...
What's it called?
Inotak and Daoko.
And some other DJs.
So obviously at DJ events.
I never stayed late for Mogra though.
I always left before the final train when I went to Mogra though.
Because...
My apartment was really far from Akiba.
It was so sad because I...
Because I barely went to Akiba when I last...
When I last was in Japan.
Because I was always so far away.
And also...
I'm also an old lady.
I can't stay out so late.
I stay...
I usually...
If I stay out late...
It's like the latest is like 3 a.m.
Which is still pretty late.
I don't like to ruin my sleep schedule so much.
Where I'm like up at first train.
You know?
3 a.m.
is pretty late.
It is.
But...
It's not as bad.
Do better, Vtuber.
What's that?
We're donating?
No!
And 3 a.m.
is like...
Is like...
The latest I'll do.
You know?
Maybe I am Oji-san if 3 a.m.
isn't late.
No, everyone that says 3 a.m.
is late is also Oji-san.
Everyone that says 3 a.m.
Some people are naturally night owls.
I get all my...
I get all my work done at night usually.
You know?
So...
It's okay.
We can be Oji-san together.
I'm Oji-san and I'm proud.
Yeah!
Putting my luck into this PayPal.
Time capsule.
So Vid can have some...
Why am I so big?
Some lucky poles when this Dodo finally reaches her.
Thank you, Gopal.
I'll use that in Blue Archive.
I'll use it in Blue Archive.
Thank you.
I haven't spent so much in Blue Archive.
Maybe...
I've spent less than $100 in Blue Archive.
For sure.
Probably even less than $50 in Blue Archive.
So...
Not that much.
Are you going to be chasing for the Railgun collab?
I don't know.
I want to.
Because...
Because she'll never come...
They'll never come back.
But at the same time...
I really want Dress Hina.
So I'm like...
What do I do?
I save for Dress Hina or...
Did you get Miku?
No.
I didn't get Miku.
I missed Miku.
So...
we'll see.
I got Miku.
She's kinda bad.
Really?
Yeah, I know Dress Hina is permanent.
I don't know.
I feel like when they do limit... like...
Thank you!
What if instead of trains and taxis, motorcycle?
Like taking a motorcycle?
I'm even too afraid to ride a bike in Japan.
Not gonna lie.
I'm too afraid to ride a bike.
I'll never drive anything.
I will walk everywhere.
Thank you!
But... I feel like for characters that are like limited where they're...
Where they're... like they'll never come back.
Like Miku or the Railgun collab.
Stuff like that.
I feel like they don't make them on... make them very good on purpose because... like...
I don't know.
Because if you get them and you miss out... or rather if you miss out like...
Because if you get them and you miss out...
or rather if you miss out like...
It would be so sad missing out on such a good character.
You know what I mean?
And the same mentality until I needed to get a license?
I drive... here!
But I don't drive in Japan.
Black Rock Shooter in PGR is also pretty weak.
Yeah...
What do you mean Stinky Minto?
But the scenes though... true.
But the scenes though...
true.
Oh my gosh, did you guys see...
With the ReZero collab for Nikkei...
Okay, when I saw like the previews for it...
I was... I was actually... pretty disappointed.
I was like...
Some coin for the Rail Dress Cup button.
Stop!
Stop it, please.
If you ever feel the need to donate, never donate because of gacha.
It makes me feel so dirty.
But...
I was so disappointed by the ReZero because...
Where's the jiggle?
That's all Nikkei is.
Well, not all.
But it's a lot.
Just no jiggle.
It's so sad.
So disappointing.
But it was cute.
They were very cute.
I heard the ReZero collab was super rushed.
Really?
Interesting.
I don't know why it would be but...
Request of the rights holder.
I was thinking that too.
But...
I was thinking of that too but...
But it's Nikkei.
You... it's...
It's that kind of game, you know?
Like...
I feel like it's really weird to be like...
Oh, by the way, don't...
Don't make them jiggle even though that's like the appeal of your game.
You know?
I don't know.
A few months ago, a Vtuber graduated and she mentioned she liked getting supers from fans talking of their achievements that motivated me to stick to gym.
I've lost 5 KGs since then because of her?
Let's go!
Oh my gosh!
Chosen!
That's so awesome!
What a coinky dink!
I also like hearing about your achievements.
Holy cow!
Big W!
Oh my gosh!
Let's go!
What's kilogram in American?
I don't know actually.
Let's see.
One kilogram is 2 pounds.
It's a little over 10 pounds.
It's a little over...
2.5 pounds to kilogram.
So yeah, 11 pounds.
How much is that in hamburgers?
Like...
Wait.
Hold on.
4 quarter pounders.
4 times 11.
44!
Burgers.
That's a lot of meat.
I lost 44 burgers!
Yeah!
44 burgers!
I don't want a burger.
Go to items, gifts, donate gifts to gain star dust.
50 star dust buys one summon ticket from the shop.
I don't think I have enough items though, right?
Wait.
I also don't want to give away my gifts if I'm going to give them to...
If I want to level up Hoshino, right?
Oh!
I forgot...
I'm just using...
I'm just putting everything that I've gotten.
You probably have enough for one ticket.
For one...
One pull or...
Or...
10 pull.
Inume, please.
You said you're back.
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
One pull.
Yeah.
Oh, that's not worth it then.
That's not worth it.
You can get free stuff in the VIP tab since you bought jade.
Oh, really?
VIP.
Where is that?
Via...
Under event?
From the buy jade menu?
Yeah, I have to buy these too.
No way.
880.
Oh my gosh.
It's $15 per...
Per outfit?
It hurts.
It hurts so bad.
Chance to change failures to success.
Yay.
I still don't see the VIP tag though.
We are number one.
I kind of...
I miss...
I really enjoy...
I miss that, like, time on the internet when everyone was just collectively making we are number one mashups.
Everybody unified for that song.
Everyone unified for that guy.
You know?
Jade buying menu VIP time.
Did I miss it?
Oh wait, this is just the shop.
So, okay.
So I have to go here.
Ah, here we go.
Here we go.
Clang.
I clang some things.
I don't know what these are though.
Yeah, Stephen Karl.
That guy was so awesome.
Yeah.
Ripped to a legend.
I know.
Everyone like came together because of him and...
Oh wait there's more.
Clang.
Successfully clang.
Wow.
Clang.
Whoa.
Nice.
We got so much.
This is so cute.
He was also super cool about it and clearly loved all the memes too.
You can use that dust to buy gacha tickets.
What's the dust?
This?
No, these are... Oh, this dust.
Star dust.
Is there like a transfer?
Like a... Star dust to Jade?
100 star dust equals two rolls.
Really?
Go to the shop.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
Handholding for the win.
Handhold me.
Fortune tap.
Oh!
Here we go.
And I have... How many do I have?
What's a rename scroll?
You may change your nickname and... Oh.
What?
Why does it cost actual money to change my name?
Oh, I have 100.
Okay.
No way.
That's so expensive even.
I'm not a veteran of the game.
Yo star, why?
I don't
have enough.
Okay.
Let's do this one then.
Why not?
What's this one do anyway?
One random green gift.
One random purple gift.
Interesting.
You know what, whatever.
Well, I couldn't summon once.
Tap.
I think they gave one rename ticket out for free at some point.
That's crazy!
This is the only one?
Okay, re-summon.
This is the one.
Ooooooh...
Haaaaa!
Okay...
What if you...
What happens if you...
get a dupe?
You still have three single pulls.
I'm thinking I'm using them because...
If I buy... let's see.
Wait, if I get... wait...
480...
This one would be close, right?
The blue donut...
It's so...
It's a little off...
Yeah...
We'll just do the solo...
Let's do...
Let's do it.
We have a couple.
Nnnnnnnnnnnn...
Cha!
Girl...
Diamond...
One... two more.
Ooooooh...
Uuuh...
Really like the art style...
Blue archive in Mahjong Soul.
But I think I'll pass.
Trying to rehabilitate from gacha.
Only blue archive currently.
That's basically me, Hyrule.
I only have one gacha that I actually...
Like...
Try...
Even in this game...
Like the gacha...
Feels...
Maybe it's more expensive because like...
In this, you really don't have to do the gacha.
You know what I mean?
Like in other games, you get gacha...
You get other characters for like special abilities.
But in this game, it's like...
Just cosmetic.
So maybe that's why it's kind of more expensive, right?
I want to head pat Hoshino.
So...
I kind of understand it.
Like in other games, it's like...
You know...
You get characters to get...
To do better damage and do stuff like that.
But...
Here it is just Mahjong.
You can totally play without paying anything.
So...
I mean, not to say that you have to pay for other...
Like you know, other gacha games too.
But...
I get it, I get it.
A little bit.
Okay.
There's one really funny thing about Hoshino.
It is her recollection.
If you look up Hoshino's recollection...
Charlie!
Thank you for the five gifted.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
If you look up Hoshino's recollection...
In Blue Archive...
Oh my god.
Her face...
Is so...
Dumb.
It's so...
It's so silly.
She goes to...
She goes to the aquarium.
And like...
It's the live 2D where her eyes are just like...
Bugging out of her head.
And she goes like...
Her eyes are literally like...
Bugging out.
It's so funny.
Let me see if I can find a picture.
Let's see.
Hoshi...
Recollection.
Oh no.
There's none that shows her...
Buggy eyes.
Boo!
I'm back.
Welcome back!
This is for you!
Hmm... I wonder if there's like...
A gif of it.
No.
It's just her standing there.
I need the movement.
I need the...
There are videos on YouTube?
Yeah.
Let me turn off the audio real quick.
Because I don't want it to play.
I don't want to get copyright...
Struck by anybody.
Let's see.
Okay.
There we go.
Head pat Hoshi.
Where does she do the...
Oh there it is.
Oh my god!
So funny.
Ooooooooh...
Ooooooooooooh...
It's the movement too, with it, it's just her eyes...
Her Buggy...
Ooooooooooooh...
Ooooooooh...
Oooooooooh...
Ooooooooooooh...
It's so funny.
I like saying it every time.
It makes me laugh every time.
Some of you have been asking for W3.
Oh my God!
It's like...
Oh God!
It's so scary!
Every time I blink...
There we go.
It's just a little bit wobbly.
Thank you guys again for teaching me how to play Mahjong.
A little bit at least.
I will keep practicing.
I will keep playing.
One day I would like to do some sort of tournament.
I don't know.
Maybe it's a lot of pressure though.
Maybe I'll just play for fun.
Who knows?
I don't know.
Maybe I'll just play for fun.
I just wait.
Uwaaa...
Good evening everybody!
I'm gonna go...
And let my brain rest for a little while.
Sensei, it's so hot out here!
Thank
you so much!
Thank you!
It was you guys!
See you tomorrow for our tour of Akihabara!
I'm so excited.
I'm so excited to go around Akihabara.
Thank you for the stream.
Later man.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
See you later.
See you.
Thank you guys.
Bye bye.
I saved my notes so I have them.
I saved my notes.
So I will be prepared.
I will study the blade.
I will study the tie.
I am ready.
Look at me kicking my little feet.
This is so cute.
I should get an updated one.
Like of my new outfit.
My current outfit.
The outfit I've been using.
Have a good night.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you.
What
is the name for simpler times?
Times that are simple.
Stimes.
Are they kicking his adorbs?
Yeah.
I like this one a lot though.
I don't know if this artist... this was actually like a your character here thing.
So the artist like had a template and I just like... I was like oh my gosh this is perfect.
It was during Halloween.
So I got it.
It's just so cute.
Or archive stimes.
Stimes gate.
Times to simple.
No.
Hi.
What's your main choice?
Well you do love Halloween so it fits.
I love Halloween.
I'm a spooky ghost.
My birthday is the start of Halloween.
Sorry.
Garfield.
Bye!
...